one of the strangest things about
relationships is that we're not free to
feel attracted to just anyone
we tend to have very strong
psychological types that we can't
deviate from all of us carry inside us
very specific inner shopping lists
defining what the people we can love
need to be liked as characters you might
think these shopping lists would be
focused around lovely requirements like
that our potential lovers would need to
be kind understanding friendly and from
our age and social group but the
shopping lists are in fact often a lot
weirder and darker we may end up
neglecting all sorts of potential
candidates dismissing them as boring or
yucky or somehow just wrong and heading
straight to people whose characteristics
are pretty awkward and not conducive to
our happiness for example we may only be
able to fall in love with people who are
much less clever or responsible than we
are or who are really unreliable who are
selfish and self-absorbed or sarcastic
and mean it can be very puzzling to
those around us and to ourselves why on
earth can't we settle down with people
who are good for us that's because what
we're looking for in love isn't
necessarily someone who is nice pure and
simple but someone who feels familiar
and a lot of us learnt about love in
childhood at the hands of people who
were in a variety of ways trouble for us
and who continued unconsciously to guide
our love types our earliest caregivers
give us templates of what it is to love
and be loved which can cause havoc with
our chances of happiness the trickiness
in our love types tends to go in one of
three ways let's imagine dad was cold or
violent or abusive or mum was belittling
unavailable or controlling it was
horrible yet that ends up being what we
look for in love why would we ever
repeat something that was deeply
uncomfortable well because even though
it was horrible it was still a love
relationship there was abuse but also
let's imagine a degree of familiarity
admiration attachment and even
tenderness they may have been belittling
but it's what we got used to and now
however illogical it sounds it doesn't
quite feel right unless it's kind of
awful as
it's not nice as such but it feels
comfortingly compellingly familiar or
imagine we experienced firsthand what it
was like to be made to feel terrible to
be humiliated and hurt and then weirdly
we may end up doing the same thing to
someone else humiliating them in turn
bossing them about going cold on them
just when they're vulnerable to us it's
as if a primitive part of us thinks that
the only way not to be abused is to be
the abuser deep inside that childlike
emotional self thinks the person who did
that thing to me was in a way the
opposite of me and that must be the
place of safety and that's who I want to
be in any relationship when parents
causes trouble were often so keen to get
away from it we develop blocks around
all kinds of character traits they may
have had which might actually have been
good and actually unrelated to the
troublesome traits so for example our
father might have been belittling but
highly intelligent now regrettably
anyone intelligent can seem hugely
off-putting or we always felt our mother
was somehow revolted by sexuality ours
especially but she was really warm and
cuddly now sadly anyone who's warm and
cuddly is imagined to be punitive around
sex and hence feels wrong and has to be
rejected our inner love maps are really
hard to tease out they certainly don't
spell themselves out so we have to make
efforts to find out what they're
dictating so as to free ourselves from
their demands the investigation starts
as always by trying to understand
ourselves what did I suffer from at the
hands of my early caregivers am i
finding myself drawn to that in adults I
fancy am i causing trouble for people in
ways I might have suffered from when I
was young and am I put off certain
people because they have traits I
associate with people who caused me
difficulties as a child might I in other
people find the traits I like without
the ones I fear emotional health means
expanding on the number of people with
free to fall in love with we learn about
love in childhood but we liberate
ourselves from the traumas of childhood
when we realize we can love in different
ways and get used to something that may
at first
be eerily and challengingly unfamiliar
being happy with someone who is properly
and deeply good for us
you